questa questo introduzione mi rimarrà
nel cuore per il resto la mia vita è da
tutti ragazzi e benvenuto che sono video
sono fa vj oggi sono tornati su che è un
gioco bello e quindi ragazzi mentre
guardate cerco di sofia minati vino al
naso sempre che non riesca al cervello
muri di bastardi che i coriandoli i
coriandoli il coriandolo no non l'avevo
che c'è un buco in fondo lega ragazzi è
l'oppio fa male e lo più fa male poco da
fare sono morto è stato un bel gioco fin
che durante successo così ma cazzo c'è
mi risveglio dentro un circo bene ditemi
se vi sembra normale come co2 cazzo
siamo sono delle tende ma è un bel gioco
credete no veramente duro
ricapitolando ragazzi tutto quello che è
successo sono andato in giro come un
drogato non ho capito che cazzo mai
detto ma dal tono di voce sembrava che
tu volessi violentarmi prova posso cielo
la torcia non c'è più cazzone
l'accendino allenatore non so più niente
probabilmente anche nudo se riuscisse a
vedermi anche solo i piedi e interrompe
dai andiamo in giro per casa gli amici
rowe nudi corriamo nudi cos'è una
persona è un sarah jessica parker salve
[ __ ] [ __ ] che succede mi si è chiuso
tutto cosa non voleva è stato bello
buongiorno era un tavolo con del pepe
possa prendere il pepe grazie grazie
1180 walsh boardgame vabbè importa io
vado avanti grazie molto gentili dove
siamo adesso tili apriti riapriva
affanculo ragazzi mi hanno chiuso dentro
non ho chiuso dentro perfetto perfetto
meraviglioso va bene non fa niente
troverò un'altra uscita una donna di
morte qualsiasi cosa è chiuso in sto
gioco non è possibile di qua nome della
cosa bella è che no no vi prego se
torniamo no no non nel posto di prima
emergency springer sistema entriamo qua
dentro che mi sembra molto accogliente
ovviamente dovrò tirarla questa forte
eco perfetto quantin chilometri di tende
avete comprato porca [ __ ]
vabbè tiriamo perfetto finito il gioco
c'è bisognava soltanto chiudere la
valvola può ovviamente le scale non ci
sono più ma non mi faccio domande vado
avanti tanto ho montato che sono molto
meno alcolizzato di prima sbando sempre
un pochettino ma probabilmente sboccato
a terra perché non tanto la correction
mi chiamo hanno sparato in faccia è
sempre una giornata di merda quando ti
sparano in faccia chi cazzo era quello
legato dove siamo ragazzi oh mio dio è
una roba indecente questo gioco se
successo perché uno mi ha sparato in
faccia di preciso ma ho ripreso la mia
roba se da allora un cucchiaio posso
mangiarci la nutella però non ho la
nutella quindi posso tranquillamente
provare a mangiare la cacca e vedere se
allo stesso sapore non ci prova così
posso spaccare il muro cosa sta
succedendo ragazzi non ho capito
porca [ __ ] ma stai zitto che stordì
so much visto incagliato in mano lurido
se urli un'altra volta ti ammazzo la
famiglia te lo dico ancora con la torcia
tramazzo o con l'accendino adesso red
ciao bell'uomo senta lei è un po magro
no vabbè
un pochettino di addominali che gli anni
che mi aprì resti questa porta non
ascolta se io io spengo la luce mi metto
qui nutella zio ti assicuro che nutella
e anche se dall'odore dal colore può
sembrare una roma un po più però e
nutella tra docce qualche modo per
uscire senza che quello lì mi stupri si
apre ascoltami io sto bene sto benissimo
qui dove sto molto bene qui guarda è
bello molto accogliente lazio ci
chiariamo tu non mi tocchi io non ti
brucio il pisello sempre più labile tra
il pisello ce l'hai non mi toccare che
ti ammazzo non mi ha toccato benissimo
via dai [ __ ] prima che torni dove
siamo l'inter e sapri veloce della
benzina da dargli fuoco ma per via di
piuttosto a [ __ ] pt veloce veloce mio
ultimi giorni messa mettono una sicura
di pile vai affanculo
eh no però eh no e non si fa così ma chi
è quel modello di abercrombie che ogni
tanto mi compare davanti a caso sta
gente che va vere serre turillo non
inter sono batterie della torcia quelle
ma va io penso fosse lo faccio la sono
cascati
no no no no no no no no no un cazzo sei
identificati uomo brutto non si scoprirà
mai ragazzi chi a parole non proprio
quell aspetto bello
di chi si tiene in forma perche i
diavoli un 9 a questo povero cristiano
che vediamo ogni tanto ad enti che ti
chiamerò ferdinando visto che cioè la
faccia molto da ferdinando e rosa volte
di ferdinando
ma prima di lei crolla allora sentite o
è ferdinando che si esercita la classica
o non mi spiego questo terremoto io non
voglio sapere niente dalla vita vado 18
ferdinando che così facendo ascoltare
no no no no stop io ti consiglierei un
buon dentista ecco bene veramente
ragazzi francesco tizio generators mi ha
mai generato ha rigenerato originata di
qua ai cagato sul boiler e non voglio
sapere via di borsa che ci leviamo dalle
palle che è meglio un'altra tessera
ancora non ne bastava una memo in altra
adesso si giocatori voglio tirati su
ho acceso con aver funzionato un cazzo
però vabbè l'importante è crederci
ovviamente non so dove sto andando ma ok
possa accendere luci grazie a dio tanto
la porta e io sono arrivato da qua
ragazzi da qua da questa cosa si è
murata da sola i casi sono due o
ferdinando è un muratore professionista
però non sembra oppure sono io pazzo
maniaco prova bellson dettagli per solo
da tener giù su che non si accende cazzo
ascoltami c'è uno funzione l'altro nome
che problemi hai tu dalla vita perché
devi sentirti un generatore diverso
dagli altri se è così bello anche tu
gira occhi giro io metto un criceto
piuttosto a girare c'è un tubo
incastrato nella ruota bene perché 4
richiamo che i tubi ragazzi comunque a
parte sta roba dovrei riuscire ad
accendere il generatore se dio vuole
perfetto grandi adesso talmente veloce
che penso decolli oppure va in
autostrada una delle due io mi ci metto
sopra non si per sicurezza si apre la
porta e sanchez i generatori sì che si
apre dai dai
se offerta grazie a dio mezz'ora proprio
sta merda riporta non vorrei dire però
che cosa siamo usciti veramente allora
cambia spengo spengo perché non ci posso
credere
siamo usciti io non entrerò mai l'ha mai
più nella vita proprio c'è io starò qua
morirò tra le nell'erba mi fumerò l'erba
tanto sono i drogati bene ti fanno
assaporare l'uscita ma non è neanche
tanto bagato mi dicono va bene sì sì ma
mi succede anche a me ogni tanto quando
esco di casa lampeggiano i muri succede
quando belli e soprattutto ok va beh io
non faccio finta di non aver visto il
muro che lampeggia e vado avanti
di qua comunque ragazzi è stato
istruttivo riuscire a far partire un
generatore mi è piaciuta la cosa adesso
dovrei riuscire ad andare avanti perché
il soffitto crolla lo devo ancora capire
ma va bene uguale andiamo avanti anche
se il block di no siamo tornati a veron
prima benissimo ci sono nuove zone meno
quello però sti cazzi il cane prigione
mi chiami nicolò troppo outlast a
barbariga io non apro un cazzo se mi
spunta qualcuno salve io non vorrei
guardare dentro ogni stanza però la
curiosità mi spinge a farlo non c'era
niente non c'è ne pensavo peggio chi
sono veramente peggio perfetto ancora ci
sono già passato di qua chiazzo basta
cioè non veramente sto gioco ti porta
allo stremo della sanità mentale
orribile di qua 3 in 1 fagioli 3 in una
ragazzi da approfittatene
io vado avanti da solo c'è me ne sbatto
dell'fda devo mettere una testa perfetto
non cielo ci mancherebbe che non ci
siano porte con le tessere ma permette
alle tessere nelle porte ci sono solo io
sto cristo di avete mica graffiato la
porta a pregare no no no
adesso vi calmate ragazzi gli altri
porti a merda che ho sentito un rumore
fortissimo di sopra e non ci vado sopra
ma neanche fosse l'ultima cosa che
faccia da sfondo attestata è bruttissimo
non posso trovare una chiave qui non lo
trovate su per forza ragazzi
ma perché dovete no sto scherzando
chianocco è caduto tutto non c'erano i
fagioli prima perché perché
sono volti fagioli regate succede
succede l'importante che abbiano vissuto
bene io vado via è crollato tutto non
sono stato io quello il problema
permesso
si è aperta questa si aspetta che mi
servono due chiavi e porcaccia ladra che
cosa ci spero ancora fare che
[Applauso]
[Musica]
oh gesù benedetto bambino cosa cazzo era
quella roba oggi oddio no vabbè che
bell'orologio che c'hai te l'ho fatto mi
è leggermente caduta una cuffia però son
dettagli posso stare qui che più bello
bene mi hanno stuprato sono cose che
succedono
e però avete rotto il cazzo cosa cazzo e
social non diamo qui le celle ma certo
tanto non guarda non ho fatto abbastanza
incontri spiacevoli se per caso avete
qualcuno a presentarmi complimenti e per
il tizio mi son tanto che è stata
un'esperienza indimenticabile me lo
ricordo è amore a prima vista è
ferdinando è sempre più bello ragazzi
hashtag kart for ferdinando per farli
fare un lifting qualcosa c'è una campana
che è una scuola questa veramente bravo
ha detto che la più bella della mia
dall'inizio proprio allora sentite e non
ho capito ancora si generatori di merda
basta vi prego cargo bay
ok anche l'inps o sbloccato di preciso
basta che non ci sia gente brutta m a me
va bene però da avvisatemi c'è ditemelo
prima c'è qualcuno che sta saldando che
cazzo questa roba è un ascensore un
accessorio perfetto devo metterci
qualcosa dentro per forza allora
aggiustiamo sta roba e andiamo a sé
fuori dalle palle che non è possibile
belli stiletti no veramente un
dormitorio complimenti mettete la lucina
prima di dormire no che serve io ve lo
dico per non si sa ma ci avete anche
fissato sul materasso ma bravi mio nome
lo pulisco erano fatte poi da soli
complimenti sempre più a fondo ma bravi
ho trovato ho trovato un corsivo è va
bene dovrei staccare sta roba e metterla
di sopra come lo riparo quel cribbio di
ascensore spiegatemelo copriamo presunte
cosa dove quando cosa è successo no non
sono via via via via via via via via via
via via via via via ma cosa voi così
bello io avvio
ecco dieci minuti di soffiata di naso il
cervello ormai intanto non ce l'avevo
prima quindi uguale ragazzi spero che
video vi sia piaciuto è sempre più bello
sto gioco seriamente cosa sento servizio
preciso da solo ma che cosa che
facilmente è la tristezza dire questa
cosa dalla velocità della luce ogni
volta e quindi 6 dove è rimasto che è
memoria che non c'è un cervello e quindi
il servizio è piaciuto ragazzi consenta
sotto momento vi piace anche a pace di
facebook con i video trovate nella
descrizione so se volessi di scrittrici
euro prossimo video di kebab [ __ ] e
[ __ ] [ __ ] discreto diavolo
questo video delle ragazze